[Applaudissements]
politique le journal le parisien
décrypte la gestuelle de ségolène royal
alors je les cite ses yeux dérape
souvent vers le front comme si elle
cherchait l'inspiration aux portes de
son intelligence vous connaissez le
dealer du parisien thierry mon avis il a
de bons produits jeudi en une du figaro
sarkozy candidat pour une rupture
tranquille
j'ai le souvenir de sa rupture avec
cécilia ça n'a pas été tranquille
tranquille
d'ailleurs y aurait-il à nouveau de
l'eau dans le gaz au sapin de noël de
l'élysée cécilia est venue seule avec
son petit garçon est mignon
pour obtenir ses parrainages philippe de
villiers drague les maires ruraux alors
plusieurs promesses non au droit de vote
des étrangers non au mariage homosexuel
en revanche si j'habite en vendée dans
une famille catteau de cet enfant un
père qui dit une connerie à la minute ai
je le droit de violer mon frère cadet
pour me distraire là c'est oui oui
trois enfants myopathes ont passé une
journée entière avec barthez pauvre
gosse
c'est pas parce que tu as plus de jambes
que tu as plus de cerveau
société
c'est pire après société air france crée
sa compagnie charter transavia attention
les compagnies charters sont moins sûrs
pour cette raison après le crash de la
flash airlines les 148 corps ont été
rapatriés sur vols réguliers aucune
turbulence musique classique à bord zéro
plainte à l'arrivée la chirurgie
esthétique disque en fait également un
malheur à l'étranger pour 20% moins cher
faites vous la bouche d'emmanuelle béart
les oreilles de dany boon le menton des
frères bogdanoff
de très belles réussites
mickey rourke catherine deneuve iti
manon après la première greffe partielle
du visage une équipe américaine prépare
une greffe totale seul bémol la mobilité
des paupières n'est pas garantie en
étant si c'est raté ce que c'est pas
mieux d'avoir les yeux fermés
[Rires]
pipoles miss limousin veut représenter
la surdité ce pas mal pour représenter
la connerie on l'a vu elle sont déjà
beaucoup
surdité toujours le nouveau cd de carla
bruni sort en janvier le 23
l'élection miss france approche cette
semaine les miss étaient dans les
baléares une info gala jean pierre
foucault les a auditionné
personnellement audition oral pour miss
tahiti jean-pierre à ramer comme elle
est enduite de monoï tulle entreprend
dans la salle de bain il a fini dans la
cuisine
je ne me suis dis personne
disparue sion robert altman philippe
noiret francis girod nous quitte
malheureusement berlusconi sentir
saint palau un nous laisse que la merde
cette semaine
sport la direction du paris
saint-germain durci le ton alors cette
fois encore les frais d'hospitalisation
du supporters blessés seront prises en
charge avec en plus quelques cadeaux un
fanion des chaussettes en banque un
bandana mais au prochain coup c'est fini
qu'on aille pas nous réclamer une
écharpe on est bien d'accord la halle
fois que les petites [ __ ] du front
national jeunesse ça rigole plus
sport toujours
inquiétude à roland garros après cette
déclaration de vincent delerm je rêve
d'être ramasseur de balles
le temps qu il les renvoie un match peut
difficilement durer trois jours
puisque fabrice luchini sort les fables
de la fontaine en cd alors en tournage
avec klapisch fabrice n'a pas pu venir
thierry je vais essayer à ma manière de
le remplacer
salut les terriens là c'est génial
un décor d'une sobriété monacale le
palais de versailles à côté c'est un
bungalow
ardisson sur canal
la boucle est bouclée le samedi soir
thierry y interroge est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper
quatre heures plus tard avec le film x
sont dans la réponse oui sucer c'est
tromper vas-y prend là tu la sens hélas
là on comprend on comprend les lumières
tamisées les miroirs au mur les
chandeliers rdif sont habillés en noir
lui laisse son pic et le vestiaire enfin
un décor ça baise
merci
merci beaucoup jm bruneau j'aime
beaucoup bruno gaccio j'adore gaccio ça
sur le service public carolis suicide
elles sont bonnes à ce lait terrienne
c'est énorme
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus